jean paul schembri les économistes et
spécialistes de la chine
bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors comment
accueillez-vous cette réforme du système
électoral à hong kong et utiliser ce
sont des mesures que pékin entendait
adopter pour mettre fin finalement la
stabilité politique à hong kong et en
recourant cette fois ci à la réforme
électorale en élargissant le collège
électoral qui sélectionne les candidats
et en introduisant la notion de
candidats patriote c'est à dire
d'accepter que des candidatures de gens
qui sont jugés patriote c'est à voir
on va voir les effets que ça fait il est
clair que c'est plutôt que déjà une
phase assez tardive dans la remise
remise remise en ordre notre de la
situation par pékin pékin considère que
le bombardant la politique d' un pays
deux systèmes ya aussi un pays il n'est
pas question que roux qu'on devienne une
base d'activités de contestation de
subversion contre l'état chinois
ceci dit la presse de pékin
ironise en même temps sur le fait que
les états unis la chambre est encore
temps est en train de passer aussi toute
une série de lois sur les élections aux
états unis et que quand il ya les moines
avant quand les émeutiers sont qualifiés
de démocrates alors que quand il disait
métier à washington ils sont considérés
comme du ben dis donc
pékin en tout cas entend faire passer le
message comme quoi on compte désormais
ça ne vous regarde plus et de toute
façon vous pouvez toujours gesticuler
mais ça aura aucun effet sur la suite
des événements l'union européenne
n'exclut pas de prendre des mesures
supplémentaires lesquelles
des sanctions contre certaines
personnalités ou autre mais ça restera
forcément un peu symbolique je vois pas
ce que alors là aussi la presse chinoise
est assez dur avec avec l'union
européenne sur cette question en disant
que quand il s'agit de ces socialistes
catalans ou quand il s'agit du parlement
britannique qui refuse mètres décore des
membres du parlement issu de ses fans
irlandais maintenant on est sisi ne
prête pas serment de loyauté à la reine
alors voilà il considère qu'il ya deux
poids deux mesures et qu' il s'agit des
affaires intérieures de la chine et que
villes européennes pas plus que les
autres noirs vraiment à intervenir là
dans sa sélection officielle
alors parler de l'union européenne a
également dénoncé une nouvelle violation
du principe un pays deux systèmes vous
en parliez tout à l'heure pour quoi je
ne suis pas il faut demander aux
représentants vigneault m
parce que la structure politique le
système politique ou électoral
hong kong à partir de 17 et donc c'est
très différent d'avant avoir 1997 quand
c'était encore une colonie britannique
il n'y avait pas d'élection du tout
l'union européenne s'était pas beaucoup
émus à l'époque
et quelle élection existe c'est vrai
sous forme parfaite puisqu'il n'y a que
la moitié des sièges du conseil
législatif
la moitié des sièges sont réélus au
suffrage universel en 2014
il ya une tentative de raifort ou par
pékin d'étendre le suffrage universel
sur l'ensemble l'ensemble des membres du
conseil législatif mais à l'époque
c'était l'opposition démocrate qui avait
bloqué la réforme
donc effectivement on peut pékin c'est
très clair il nous toucherons pas
au fait qu'il existe travail une chambre
législative en langue qu'il y aura
toujours une vie politique autonome à
hong kong
mais ce qu'ils veulent pas c'est que le
système soit dévoyée éventuellement vers
la constitution d'un pôle de subversion
la contestation systématique avec dans
la foulée dès mars politiques qui
viennent compromettre la prospérité et
la sabika gang ce qu'ils ont constaté
pendant deux ans entre 1919 et demi de
2010 ne faiblit pas jean-paul chang
merci d'avoir été en direct avec moi je
rappelle que vous êtes économiste et
spécialiste de la chine merci